es un icono a través de la historia por razones buenas y malas.
Las capuchas más tempranas que encontramos
proceden de la antigua Grecia y la antigua Roma.
Durante la Edad Media, muchos monjes llevaban trajes
parecidos a túnicas con "capa",
de allí, "capucha".
En el siglo XVII, las damas llevaban prendas con capuchas
para esconderse en camino a estar con su amante.
Y luego, claro, está la leyenda, la fantasía.
La capucha se asocia con la Parca.
La capucha se asocia con el verdugo.
Así que la capucha tiene un lado oscuro.
La encarnación moderna de la capucha...
una prenda normalmente de jersey de algodón,
que tiene una capucha pegada y tiene un cordón,
a veces tiene bolsillo marsupial,
fue presentada en los años 30 por Knickerbocker Knitting Company.
Ahora se llama Champion.
La idea era mantener la temperatura de los atletas.
Pero claro, es una prenda tan funcional y cómoda
que fue adoptada enseguida por obreros en todas partes.
Y luego en los años 80, es adoptada también
por el hip-hop y los b-boys, los skaters,
y representa un tipo de cultura urbana.
Es a la vez súper cómoda, perfecta para llevar en la calle,
y tiene ese valor adicional de anonimato
cuando la necesitas.
Y luego tenemos a Mark Zuckerberg,
que desafía las normas de vestimenta respetable para la gente de negocios.
Curiosamente, también es una manera de demostrar cómo ha cambiado el poder.
Si llevas un traje de dos piezas, quizás eres el guardaespaldas,
y la persona poderosa de verdad lleva una capucha
con una camiseta y jeans.
Es fácil imaginar los aspectos físicos de esta prenda.
Pensamos automáticamente en la capucha puesta,
en sentir su calor y su protección.
Pero al mismo tiempo, podemos sentir los aspectos psicológicos.
Piensa en ponerte una capucha,
y de repente sientes más protección,
sientes que estás en tu propia cáscara.
Sabemos muy bien lo que ha significado la capucha
en los últimos años en EE.UU.
Cuando Trayvon Martin, un chico afroestadounidense de 17 años,
fue asesinado por un miembro de una patrulla vecinal,
hubo manifestaciones "Million Hoodie Marches"
por todo Estados Unidos,
en las cuales las personas llevaban prendas con capuchas
y desfilaron por las calles en contra a ese tipo de prejuicio.
No ocurre mucho
que una prenda encarne tanto simbolismo e historia,
y que abarque tantos diferentes universos
como la capucha.
Como todas las prendas,
particularmente las prendas verdaderamente utilitarias,
la capucha es muy básica en su diseño.
Pero al mismo tiempo,
lleva consigo un universo entero de posibilidades.